once you felt you had this green light
to go ahead or you felt you'd have
access to these journalists how was this
setting up the interviews what was that
process like tough it was tough
because we didn't you know some people
said yes and it was easy and we were
able to kind of make times and places
and meet them and others led us along
for quite a while and you know to really
down to the wire day of kind of stuff so
we had to really be patient and just let
things play themselves out
you know tabloid reporters are very
smart people and trued and want to kind
of know what what you're up to
and so gaining people's trust and saying
look this is an opportunity for you to
have a space to tell it like it was for
you rather than me and posing all my
ideas about what it was on you or trying
to frame you in a certain way so that
took a minute to get people comfortable
and then it was just about like finding
these locations and that was really at
an incredible producer named Jennifer
Ashford ik who had access to all these
beautiful places in the various cities
that we were filming in and I have a
tremendous partner in my cinematographer
Michael Pesa who just has an incredible
eye and the ability to just make really
anything look epic and that's what we
wanted to do you know we wanted to find
these locations that were a little bit
over the top because the Enquirer is
over the top and you know chasing people
around and trying to get these crazy
stories isn't over the top career so we
found all these great houses and private
clubs and restaurants and bars and
things in New York and Palm Beach
and in Los Angeles and that's what we we
situated these people sometimes they
were their own homes but most of the
time it was these vocations that we
found it was almost as if you were in
the same shoes as he is the reporter
because it seems like they went through
a lot of cat-and-mouse with people as
well yeah
getting them along oh definitely you
there was a lot of phone time and in her
emails and back and forth send kind of
you know but for some and for others it
was like yes of course I'd love to do
this this would be great I no one's ever
asked me to tell my story before so
let's do it I'd say that was a good
number of them and then there were a
couple of like really hardliners that
kind of dug in their heels for a while I
thought it was interesting to see some
of them that express some of them said
they didn't really feel that bad ly
about some of the things that happen and
others said that they felt it wasn't a
high point in their career and I just
thought it was interesting to see the
human side of what's behind this paper
yeah the the sort of the people doing
the groundwork and yeah that was a huge
one of the reasons why we wanted to make
the film was to get into the minds of
these people these these tabloid
reporters and to kind of figure out what
would make somebody want to take a job
like this and you know the film really
goes into that the film really looks at
okay so what was this career like what
were the what were the perks and what
were the downsides of it and that was
really fascinating and the stories that
were killed even though the reporters
went and got them oh yeah and a lot of
these reporters did amazing jobs getting
the stories but then getting the stories
printed was a whole other thing that
wasn't up to them and I was up to the
editors and ultimately up to the people
on top you know it's not a comfortable
movie it's not me to make you
comfortable it's a it's it's a film
that's going to agitate you and
hopefully get you thinking
so if
if it does that it's great connealy ate
some people and they think and it pisses
them off great
great that's why we're making films and
we're not making films to sedate people
and or make them super comfortable or
serve up for them exactly what they need
you know there's other there's other
things out in the culture that are doing
that you know the purpose of a
documentary film or really any film I
don't think it's to be an opiate I think
it's to be like some smelling salts you
know sometimes people don't like what
they're waking up to it's not our
problem were there parts of the story
that you wish you'd followed up on more
closely were there things that you
didn't get were there things that you
felt you left out or maybe you shouldn't
have put in I think
I'll tackle the first one because that
really resonates yeah I mean we wish
that we could have dove way deeper into
the catch and kill story and gotten into
really what happened with Karen McDougal
what happened with stormy Daniels like
you know but we realized that if we had
done that that would have been the
entire film and then we wouldn't have
been able to really answer the first
question that made us make the film
which is how the hell did we get here we
really wanted to create a sort of like a
reverse engineering of how we got to
this crazy moment where you know women
are having their stories suppressed for
money and we're powerful political
figures are are partnering with powerful
media entities to keep negative stories
out of the public's attention in order
to rise in the polls and all of that
stuff we so but we of course I would I
would love to have gotten an opportunity
to have included Karen McDougal
and Stephanie Clifford in the film I'm
you can only do so much you know I mean
I think that's also that's that's the
challenge too is like when do you what's
the frame around your story what's the
timeframe what are the resources that
you have to work with you know 60 years
of American pop culture it was a lot to
tackle so we just had to make choices
you know and do the best we could
once you saw the first cut on the
editing timeline what were your thoughts
what did you feel that you needed to tie
up or finish or a door I mean editing is
arduous and crazy my first thought when
I saw the first cut was my god we got so
much work to do but I had the incredible
opportunity to grow to amazing editors
Andrea Lewis and that Daughtery and so
we were like a three-headed monster and
they're incredibly gifted editors
incredible filmmakers so everything was
put through this incredible scrutiny you
know times 3 because we have three heads
in the editing room I mean it's it's
it's amazing to have one editor it's an
incredible gift to have - and we needed
that because we had so many hundreds of
hours of archival to sift through and
all these stories to tell from the 50s
to the 2000s and just so much work to do
but that allowed us to get really really
kind of intense and tight with our
storytelling so the first cut you know I
mean I think most of us who make films
are kind of cringing at the first guy
sure but yeah but what it is though at
the first cut it's like it's a it's a
benchmark you get there and and and it's
and it's a great moment because you know
that you've got something to work with
you know goes from like total
amorphousness to something
and aside from obtaining the interviews
was getting clearance on the archival
footage the the second most
time-consuming thing Oh without a doubt
without a doubt got to work with an
amazing archive producer named um Amy
and Silverstone she's worked with Jordan
Peele on the Lorena Bobbit and project
she's she's really say she's kind of
like the guru of archive and she was
amazing to work with and we but it was
it's it's a lot of that is just like
needle in haystack kind of stuff
especially if you're looking for archive
that the public hasn't seen before
a lot of archive most people are
familiar with you know there are classic
shots of especially with
liberties and stuff like that so finding
the rare archive that was that was
really challenging and then figuring out
whether or not we could afford that we
ended up fair using a lot of stuff which
was a godsend because that saved a
tremendous amount money from the budget
and fair use I think is a real
filmmakers gift to be able to know that
you're actually entitled to use certain
things depending on how you use them
gratis and that that was um that was
amazing for us in a certain time period
yep all that yeah yeah I mean there's
very strict rules and you have to spend
money to hire a really responsible law
firm to go through and vet literally
every single shot every frame
it's very arduous process but you
ultimately end up being able to use
material that can make your film and
that's what we as we did we had so much
powerful archival footage one that stuck
out to me and maybe this has been around
and I just hadn't seen it before was the
George Clooney sort of yeah proclaiming
to the crowd what what an invasion of
privacy and how damaging this is and
yeah you know you don't really think
about that you just think I want to know
about George Clooney in his love life
but then to see him as a human and you
can see it on his face that it is
damaging and we don't know everything
that's been said and how much is true
and how much isn't but just the fact
that it's a human and their life is
there for all of us to pick apart was
very powerful yeah that piece of are
kind of incredible yeah yeah all the
archive around the Princess Diana
tragedy that that we found I thought was
it was pretty amazing much of it I
hadn't seen a guy hadn't seen shots of
her and her children in on ski slopes
before and the press just trying to just
constantly invade her life like that he
just realized that she just had no she
had no privacy and they hounded her
right you know and you could see how
ultimately that resulted in a tragedy
and how she handled it - she was quite
polite I remember one scene that you had
it was almost I mean it made you sad at
least
and it was very emotional to see that
she didn't she wasn't ugly about it in
that moment when most people you could
see why people would throw punches or do
different things I mean if this was
something that was a daily occurrence
yeah it was interesting that you showed
that you know it was a very pro-american
you know support our troops for some of
the the stories and and the political
showcasing but it have if it had been a
little more trying to think of the word
if that if it had been less oh let less
pro-american do you think that the paper
would have survived you know I don't
know I don't have the answer you know
it's it so hypothetical I don't I don't
know um you know Generoso Pope and the
editors of The Enquirer knew their
readership they understood their
readership and their readers were
patriotic their readers were proud to be
American and so they served up to that
readership what would appeal to them you
know Charlton Heston's stories you know
all kinds of stories stories of the USO
you know that's just understanding their
readership and they continue to do that
through the years I mean you have Steve
cause it was the former editor in chief
for ten years and the Enquirer really
and it's kind of heyday in the 90s in
terms of the stories it was breaking say
you know at our core Steve said at the
core the readership was was was
patriotic so you see the content of the
paper reflecting that um I have no idea
what the paper would have been like had
it been otherwise how would I know
sure yeah what lessons did you learn for
the National Enquirer on storytelling I
think that what lessons did I learn
researching the national enquirer i
learned that you can take a story and
you can spin it in all kinds of ways
depending on the way you frame it
depending on the information you choose
to include the information you choose to
exclude the guys that they inquire the
men and women the query they were expert
at that they were experts at that and so
what I learned from working on a film
about the Enquirer for a year is that
there's a real art and science to that
what I also learned is that that doesn't
serve the truth that serves circulation
and sales and you can spin a story and
make it seem like something happened
when it didn't or make innuendo and
really sway public opinion about a
person or an event one way or another
but that's not telling the real story so
I learned that too do you think people
want to read the real story I would hope
so
I mean why not I mean but the thing to
remember for me is that the real story
is never from one single outlet it's
like you know Kurosawa made Rashomon
right it's like any event can be viewed
from seven different perspectives and
everybody's coming with their own biases
and their own filters about what
happened but there has to be some
objective understanding of what truth is
otherwise we're living in a chaotic
world you know I know I'm sitting here
looking at a human being in front of me
and she's connect you know what we're
talking I know that this is happening
right how do I know that this is
happening there's some sort of an
objective understanding here of truth
right so I would call that a fact you
know the fact that we are having a
debate about what that word means truly
that's really alarming to me as a
filmmaker as a human as a parent you
know so I hope the film at the very
least will get us
we'll get people kind of continuing to
talk about that because I personally
believe that we we do want to know as
much of the story as we possibly can
you